hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game you guys requested i show uh
it's from the norwegian league and it's
the first game magnus uh is playing uh
ever since uh his great victory in the
tata still uh this year uh so he's
playing against gerson talcasinos
i have no idea if that's how it's
pronounced but i'm going to go with that
and well it's very important for magnus
not to lose any classical points he
announced that he wants to get that 2900
classical elo rating and well you know
that he won uh some three points uh for
the tata still and if he loses against
this gentleman uh well then it's not
going to be all that great for his goal
because uh what's more here is some 400
rating points lower rated than magnus so
magnus should be very careful but he has
the white pieces uh let's see what
happened here so magnus opens with e4 we
have c6 the karo khan defense and magnus
goes for knight to f3 d4 is by far the
most popular knight to f3 uh magnus uh
showing that he's ready to go for
something different uh we have d5 black
strikes in the center right away and
magnus plays d3 now saying that he is
okay with a queen trade already as of
move four so the captures on e4 we have
d captures and queen captures on d1 so
the queens are already off the board and
well
most people would not enjoy playing such
a position against magnus or goes for it
king captures on d1 knight to d7 now we
have knight b to d2 and e5 grabbing more
space in the center we have knight to c4
now putting pressure on this e5 pawn and
uh osmo defends it with f6 we have
knight after d2 and it is now already as
of move eight that we have a completely
new game so knight to c5 um
you could also consider developing some
other pieces maybe knight h6 knight to
f7 knight to d6 but knight to c5 this
move allows magnus to really uh get you
know build up an initiative on the queen
side and he does so he starts with a4
next he's going to play b4 and make use
of this knight on c5 so bishop to e6 now
just b4 chasing away the knight knight
back to d7 and now c3 uh we have knight
to h6 black has to also bring the pieces
into the game he wants to play knight to
f7 knight to d6 to challenge white's
knight on c4 and now we have king to c2
we have to bring the king away from the
center of the board and into the uh into
the game we have knight to f7 knights to
b3 and now knight to d6 attacking the
knight here and okay magnus straight
with knight captures bishop captures and
now knight to a5 going after the uh
undefended b7 pawn uh so smoya castles
uh king defends the pawn now and the
bishop the c4 so another offer of a
trade and uh osmo accepts with bishop
captures knight captures and bishop to
e7 now so pieces are getting traded off
black is very very happy with himself we
have bishop to e3 now putting pressure
on the a7 pawn now b6 we defend the the
pawn and now comes rook h to d1 if you
if you try a5 then b5 so nothing to
worry about there so rook h to d1 by
magnus now king to c7 we do not want to
allow knight to d6 so now a5
and b5 just chasing away the knight and
now you normal would be to play some
like knight b3 knight b2 back knight to
d3 then maybe knight to c5 at some point
but no magnus goes nice to b6 and it's a
it's a really interesting idea uh
because it doesn't work uh black should
just capture this knight and if the
knight is captured then you get a
captures on b6 and after knight capture
cs okay you will have to give the piece
back rook to a7 check king to b8 now
bishop captures and b6 attacks the
bishop here and once the bishop moves
you're going to pick up the b7
the g7 pawn although not really black
can capture the rook and after king
captures you can play bishop to d8
and now the problem is your bishop is
hanging and you cannot capture on the 8
because king captures rook so you're
going to have to move the bishop back
and then we just play bishop to c7 and
we've defended our pawn and black is
perfectly fine white is more active but
black should be should be okay so knight
to b6 is a fine move however uh fine
moves are sometimes best just accepted
as they are so here knight back to b8
and here magnus goes for rook captures
on d8 and this the knight to b8 confused
magnus because here believe it or not a6
should be uh should be winning for white
uh the problem is
uh well look at this the the rook
controlling all of these squares the
pawn now controlling b7 the knight can
come to a8 with check it's uh quite a
crazy position bishop will be able to
capture on a7 and another thing is if of
course the the knight is captured then
we just capture on the e8 and after rook
captures and then we play a7 and that's
it white wins whatever we play knight d7
we're gonna bring a queen into the game
captures captures and now it's a rook
and bishop against the knight and bishop
of course this will be winning for white
so magnus misses this a6 idea uh he
plays rook captures on the e8 we have
bishop capture 78 and now a6 okay
still still white is better here no
doubt about that
but now black can play knight captures
on a6 and eliminated this past pawn so
knight to c4
this is a move you have to play because
now the knight is hanging and also the
a7 pawn will be very weak you're not
going to be able to defend this so black
just captures in c4 we have rook
captures on a6 king to d7 uh and rook
captures on a7 we have bishop to c7
blocking so if bishop b6 attacking the
bishop you can play rook to c8 so it's
not a problem uh magnus starts with f4
uh g4 would have been a little bit
better but okay he knows uh he knows his
plan we have f4
king the c8 by black and now f captures
an e5 we have f captures on e5 and it
seems the magnus again created a winning
position so feel free to pause the video
here and try to find this incredibly
sneaky winning move for white while i
give you a couple a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting such a
brilliant tactic you are a
truly masterful tactician and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is bishop to b6 that's the good stuff
uh point is uh
uh well now that you see it of course
you believe it but if we play rook to a8
check we cannot win the rule because the
bishop blocks will bishop to b8 but by
playing bishop to b6 we are threatening
to pick up the bishop and what can the
bishop do uh if you just capture the
bishop then rocate check we pick up the
rook here and we win the game and if you
don't do that if you play something like
bishop to d6 to always be able to block
rook a8 with a bishop to b8 then rook
captures and g7 you've lost a very
important pawn and now the position will
be winning for white so this was in the
position however magnus misses this as
well he plays rook to a8 check bishop to
b8 and now goes rook to a5
uh we have king to b7 and now b5 so
hoping to get some trades and then he's
going to eliminate both of these pawns
so rook to c8 instead black takes this
opportunity to bring the rook into the
game now b6 and okay magnus again
creates a pass pawn uh we have rook to
f8 and now comes rook to a1
we rook to f6 now black wants to
somehow uh maybe get the bishop here
play c5 move the bishop and then pick up
the pawn something like this uh so here
we have g3 uh and now h5 uh black wants
to create some weaknesses here to try
and get rid of those king side pawns
king to d2 we have rook to d6 check king
to c2 rook to f6 uh bishop to c5 now not
allowing rook to d6 and now h4 creating
weaknesses on the kings side magnus
plays rook to d1 and now h captures on
g3 we have h captures on g3 and the rook
g6 going after the g3 pawn so rook the
d7 check king to a6 and now rook to d8
going after the bishop you don't really
gain anything with rook to a7 check
because the king can go back i know some
of you are looking at this uh but king
b7 prevents the uh well stops the pawn
so instead after king a6 will rook to d8
going after the bishop now comes king
back to b7 bishop to f2 guarding our g3
pawn and rook to f6 going after the
bishop bishop to e1 and now g6 uh we
have bishop to d2 uh we are shifting the
bishop over to e3 to control uh this
square and also a guard opponent of
course the king cannot capture the pawn
the bishop would be hanging so bishop to
d6 now comes bishop to e3 not allowing
bishop to c5 and now uh black finally
plays c5 in the pawn will now fall and
look at this g4 king captures on b6 and
now it's a small who is actually up a
pawn okay c4 pawn is uh is very weak so
magnus will be able to win this one uh
but uh from from uh twice a winning
position to this not not looking great
for for carlson's uh
road to 2900 so here rook to e8 we have
king to c6
and now g5
uh attacking the rook we have king d7
offering a rook trade and now magnus
goes back rook to a8 we have rook to f3
attacking the bishop king d2 now king to
e6 we have rook to a6 uh
pinning the bishop so bishop captures
and c5 is an idea uh king e7 we just
sidestepped this thread a rook to a7
check king to f8 now rook to a4 we will
win this spawn but still it's gonna be
uh equal material bishop e7 rook
captures on c4 rook to g3 and now bishop
captures on c5 there is nothing better
you could just keep guarding the spawn
but then neither side can do any
progress so bishop captures on c5 rook
captures on g5 and now bishop to b4
uh we have rooked the g2 check king d3
rook to g3 king to c2 and now bishop
captures on b4 c captures and king to e7
so now again magnus has a pass pawn but
uh will it be enough black also has a
pass pawn so b5 we have rook to f3
making room for the for the past g pawn
rook to c5 now comes king d6 we have
brooke the d5 check king to e6 now rook
to d8 we have to prevent the rook uh
from getting behind the pass pawn and
also we want to stop it from uh
getting to that past pawn in in any way
so king e7 we have rook to g8 going
after this pawn and now king to d6 black
playing very very correctly rook
captures on g6 check king to c5 and now
b6 so we still protect our pawn now
magnus is up upon rook to f7 preventing
the pawn from reaching b7 now rook e6
attacking the e5 pawn we have king d4
the pawn is defended king b3 we have
rook to f1 king to a4 and now king
captures an e4 so again equal material
rook to d6 and now rook to b1
uh we have our rook behind the past pawn
and as you know that's always great king
a5 we have king to f3
rook to f6 check king to g3 we have
rooked f5 waiting for a push so we can
block the uh rook with rook to b5 so
here e4 rook to b5 now offering a rook
trade and rook a1 check we have king to
b4 and of course rook to a8 we will be
stopping the pawn so king c3 we have e3
black also pushes his pass pawn and king
to d3 now we have king to f4 defending
the pawn now comes b7 attacking the rook
rook to d8 check king to e2 and now rook
to b8 stopping the pawn from promoting
rook to b for check king to e5 and now
magnus even wins the e3 pawn but king to
d5 the king is now much too close to the
past pawn king to d3 with king to c6 and
that's just it there's no way to stop
rook captures on b7 so king c4 rook
captures on b7 rook captures king
captures and it is now on move 84 that
we have a draw by insufficient material
uh so big congratulations to uh to uh
osmo for achieving this um uh well great
victory over the world champion even
even if it's a draw it's a great victory
i imagine for him with the black pieces
he is some 400 rating points lower rated
than magnus and what does this mean for
magnus's road to 2900 well he won some
three points in the tata still uh
tournament for for the entire event and
for just this one game uh magnus lost
four points so it's not it's not it's
not going to be easy uh so yeah that's
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it the
very very nicely played by osmo uh
magnus had that uh chance but he missed
it and that was enough to
claim a draw
i would like to wish a very happy
birthday to nikki and i would like to
thank david kimura tripper triangle uh
daniel silverberg and john black for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the grand prix
and of course checking up on your
wonderful suggestions such as this one
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your
sunday